comment tu te sens toilé oh bah allez
laisser le parler moi je me sens bien
après c'est sûr que ça amène à se poser
des questions mes parents et faire un
choix pareil et moi on en parlait avant
et mon parlait avant et comme ils m'ont
dit si j'aurais mis en France
il l'aurait pas fait moi à travers ça
eux aussi voyaient en plus de ça une
liberté d'agir d'être et de penser parce
que nous on est tous salué dans une
liberté d'être et de parler en fait on
essaie d'avoir le moins de tabou
possible pour que on ait rien on n'est
rien à se reprocher qu'on puisse parler
tout avec nos parents et moi j'ai des
frères et sœurs et ça je peux le dire
ils savent même pas c'est quoi le sexe
donc c'est sûr ils vont pas aller
chercher eux sur Internet et des vidéos
de mes parents à poil d'ailleurs mais
moi ça me fait pas triplé de voir mes
parents sur internet donc je vais
pas le chercher parce que dans ta vie de
tous les jours est-ce que ça a changé
quelque chose moi dans ma minute dans ma
vie tous les jours non ça a rien changé
après forcément je me suis dit
peut-être même faire chier à l'école
peut-être qu'on va se de ma
gueule et tout non non moi j'ai pas vu
j'ai pas constaté je peux constater ça